Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burn.
It's the Monday morning podcast from Monday.
Ah,
Jesus.
August eight teeth.
Yeah,
that's the month.
And that's the day and it's the year 2014.
Um,
how are you?
Do you realize you wouldn't think about that.
It's 2014 if we actually make it to the 2019 how people are going to be looking
back at us like the way you know,
in the 1900 you look back at 1914 everybody was walking around really fast.
Okay.
Do you think that'll happen with us?
No.
Bill,
they have HD TV and what the rate of global warming.
Ah,
right.
Your fucking cut all going to be underwater.
Um,
you know what you know,
be funny.
A bet.
Waterworld do you think that movie will make a bunch of fucking money as the
polar ice caps start to melt everybody?
It'd be like,
you know,
I think we were wrong about this one.
We gave this movie a lot of fucking criticism.
The guy was actually way ahead of his time.
Uh,
Bill,
why are you talking about Kevin Costner?
Cause I actually have a movie coming out with Tim believe in and not old fancy
pants.
Freckled boy over here.
I did a movie last summer in a New Orleans.
Some of you listen to this podcast might remember.
Um,
and uh,
it was hot as shit,
but it was a,
it was a wonderful,
a wonderful,
those are wonderful time.
And uh,
Mike binder wrote,
directed it.
Octavius Spencer,
Kevin Costner.
Uh,
they're all in it.
It's a,
um,
how would I describe the movie?
It's a courtroom drama.
Old School courtroom drama.
And what do you play bill?
I play Kevin Costs and his lawyer Enough Boston accent in there.
Um,
I'm actually going to weigh a film festival coming up Toronto with the debut of
that movie
and uh,
or whatever at a film festival,
I guess.
And then it comes out in October.
So there you go.
Look at that.
I barely giving you any laughs.
I've come right out right out of the gate.
Just whoring myself out.
I'm actually hoping to get my car,
find her on the podcast a as we get closer to the date.
That's a,
he's actually one of the legendary standups from the comedy store back in the
day.
And,
uh,
he told me a bunch of great stories and all that stuff.
And um,
so he'll obviously be a great guest.
Speaking of which last night I went down to the,
uh,
yeah,
well the first thing I did was I went out and I fucking jam with the band.
Man.
I'm doing another one of those is a goddamn comedy jams tonight.
Uh,
and dressing up like the drama that I'm imitating again,
which of course is it's so,
it is ridiculous.
So I take off any sort of pressure for any sort of audience member where,
you know,
is there anything than having to go see your friend's band?
Even if the fuck,
unless they're really fucking good,
then you like that.
Oh God,
maybe they're gonna make it.
I should start picking up some why is,
maybe I could be a roadie
dude.
You,
you,
you forgot where you came from,
man.
You remember I used to go see you down at friendlies and the ground round.
Either way,
you're fucked,
right?
So I just don't want anybody going down to the,
anybody who's going onto this thing.
I don't want anybody even remotely to think that I'm taking this anywhere other
than this is just a fun as hell thing to do.
Um,
I want to do some jokes about Tommy Lee.
You know,
like I did with John Bonham.
It's fun.
It's just a good fucking time.
So I'll tell you,
trying to find a time you leave,
uh,
costume is,
it's fucking difficult.
The guys had like 90 different looks and like most of them,
he's not wearing a shirt and I'm just too fucking pasty essay.
I'm not fucking doing that.
So,
uh,
I did,
I had to pick an era where he was actually wearing a shirt,
which is a,
it's not easy.
It's not easy to find.
But anyway,
so,
uh,
I did that and then I went,
last night I went down to the comedy store and,
um,
they had actually had a,
a,
a memorial service for Robin Williams and,
uh,
it was awesome,
man.
It was,
you know,
just like so many people from back in the day came out that were down there.
I actually one wondering when all the last time,
all of that group of people were down there,
um,
and they were all telling stories.
I was like,
I got there late unfortunately.
But,
um,
norm McDonald schmear enough,
had some great stories.
Uh,
Jackson Purdue,
then there's a couple of people for that.
We're in part of his improv group.
We're all telling all these great stories and,
uh,
it was a really great thing,
but I gotta tell you,
man,
that was,
it's not like I knew the guy or anything,
but that was brutal.
Fucking brutal.
Okay.
When I heard the news about that one,
that one really,
uh,
okay.
You know,
there's one of those things where you really,
you think,
you know,
yeah,
I love that guy.
I love his movies.
I think that guys hilarious.
You know,
you don't realize it.
And then something like that happening,
just like,
wow,
man,
I,
I had no idea how much that guy,
uh,
affecting me.
I did get a chance,
um,
one time to do a show with them.
Uh,
he always,
um,
you know,
he would just come down to clubs.
I'd always heard about,
I know he did it.
We lived up in San Francisco,
but people saying like,
yeah,
this is open.
Mikey went to every single week.
Um,
Bart,
Nick told this great story about,
uh,
how he was at a concert.
He was Kinda like the,
like the unofficial mayor of San Francisco when they needed like a laugh or
something,
like,
I Guess Barnett was at some big concert and if it was an outdoor and it rained
and um,
you know,
so like,
apologize everybody,
the bands can't go on.
Everybody's standing there fucking looks like a bunch of fucking which shelter
dogs and stuff.
And Robin Williams was in the crowd and he just went up on stage in like a
fucking rain Poncho and did 45 minutes in front of an Oh,
soaking wet,
angry crowd that wasn't getting this show.
And he crushed,
just did like a headlining set and a,
and then in the end like the sun was coming out and he's like,
all right,
the bands are coming out with blah,
blah,
and just went right back into the crowd.
You see was like a zillion stories like that that I heard.
And um,
so anyways,
I was doing,
uh,
Jeff Garland had this show.
He does a every now and again down at the UCB and uh,
it's just really cool format.
In the end he has like this Improv game called,
uh,
the Combo platter and it's basically they pick a subject and each person has to
go up and riff on it for five minutes and then you sit down and then the next
round is you go back up again.
But anybody can interrupt anybody at any time and it just starts going and you
just start adding to whatever they're doing.
And one,
you know,
one night I went down there and I was doing the show with them and Robin showed
up and Garland knew him and everything and they went in with the show and I
actually got to do improv standing right next to him doing improv.
I literally felt like I was on comic relief,
you know?
I mean we sitting in the chairs,
right?
It's just like such a fucking weird moment.
But we always sitting in the chair next to him,
you know,
he had that thick arm hair.
It's like we were,
the space between us was a little tight but it wasn't anywhere where we still
should have been touching,
but his arm hair was so fucking thick.
It actually was.
It actually was touching my arm.
I had to move my arm.
I remember thinking all those jokes that he used to do about how he felt like he
was wearing a sweater and all that type of thing.
But it was one of the,
obviously one of the great things I ever got to do.
And fortunately because he was such an open guy and such a nice guy,
sweet guy,
he didn't,
didn't,
you know,
coming with that,
I've been doing this forever,
get out of the way kid.
He didn't have that vibe at all.
He was like a really vulnerable kind of vibe that because he came with that
vibe,
I was actually able to like enjoy it as it was happening rather than,
um,
look back on it and be like,
oh yeah,
I got to do that.
But I,
I was so in my head I had to like knock him down.
You know,
that's like something I have to do sometimes when I get a gig that's so big,
I literally have to develop a certain level of hatred for this person that I
don't hate.
I have to be like,
you know what?
Fuck this guy.
Fuck this guy for making me feel so fucking uncomfortable with this
success or whatever.
But the way Robin was,
he,
you didn't have to do that when you're him.
So,
uh,
you know,
thanks to Jeff Garlin for fucking,
having that show so I could have that memory,
but it's definitely a huge,
huge,
huge fucking a and indescribable a loss.
And um,
ah,
it just sucks.
I hate that it ends that way,
you know?
So
anyways,
isn't that happy?
Isn't that happy to fucking have to talk about that yet?
Another fucking person in his business he knows was fucking weird is I got like
three texts within 24 hours of Robin's death,
you know,
asking me if I was okay and then telling me not to kill myself.
And that just struck me as funny.
Like,
it's like depression and suicide are not like us.
Just
like a stand,
like if a fucking plumber kills himself,
it's,
do people reach out to other plumbers?
Hey Man,
I know you haven't got a lot of sinks lately.
It's been mostly toilets and uh,
you know,
just reach out that,
it's,
it's going to turn around,
you know,
you know.
Um,
oh look,
I'm not a fucking doctor,
but I know that,
that shit.
Um,
it definitely,
uh,
it definitely affects,
you know,
a lot of people.
I mean,
I've,
I've dealt with,
you know,
unfortunately and it's been okay
people outside of a standup,
well,
let's see,
I got to like count.
I think it's three.
Yeah.
Three people that I know,
you know,
committed suicide.
It's fucking brutal,
man.
It's,
it's really fucking brutal.
And,
uh,
so I got this,
you know,
I dunno,
I see somebody starting to go down that the depress road.
It's just fucking,
it's so hard to get them off.
Um,
I dunno.
All I know is it sucks.
So
back to the podcast.
Anyways,
what am I going to talk about this week?
Um,
oh,
let's,
let's just continue with like,
you know,
talking about depression and suicide.
Can I,
can I fucking just openly and honestly talk about the ice bucket challenge?
Can I do that without fucking this McCarthyism fucking era of once the ball gets
rolling,
if you fucking go anywhere else,
you're not supporting the troops.
You fucking,
you're a,
you're a commie.
You,
you hate women.
Uh,
you know,
it just that ice bucket challenge.
I,
at this point,
I've been challenged by three different fucking people.
Yeah.
Okay.
The last one was last night and it's,
this is,
this is what,
uh,
the person texted me,
said,
hey,
you know,
go check out my ice bucket challenge.
I love how it's about the person.
It's so not even about the disease.
Hey,
check out my wacky response to ice cold water over my fucking head.
And he goes,
uh,
what the hell is it?
He said,
it's on Facebook.
Um,
yeah,
hope you're good.
I nominated you for the ice bucket,
als challenge.
So I wrote back,
I said,
listen dude,
I live in a desert.
Okay,
all right.
It's a $500 dollar fine.
If your wastewater,
I'm going to do the hundred dollar donation instead.
So he goes,
you prick well played,
you can do it on the road and send me the video.
And I wrote back,
I'm like,
dude,
it's about raising money for that als.
Not what not.
You watching me dump a bucket of ice over my fucking head.
I don't under like do you understand how precious water is to everybody and
around the world,
how much does this shortage of it?
We're over here going,
dumping it over our heads and it's to the point now it's the disease is,
is second banana to watching somebody's reaction.
I know.
What's a fun fucking thing and it's raised over a hundred million dollars in all
of that type of shit.
But uh,
there's this pressure.
Like if you don't fucking do it and you just give 100 bucks,
somehow you're an asshole.
What I want to know is how many people just dump the bucket of ice over their
head and it's another fucking,
you know,
me moment for them and then they don't even give any goddamn money.
MMM.
You know,
this is just going to open a can of worm for all these other diseases is
actually people in foundations right now sitting in a board room.
Okay.
With fucking bagels and cream cheese sitting in front of him that everybody
wants to go and grab.
But no one wants to grab it first.
So they seem like the person who just came there to eat and they're sitting
there brainstorming trying to figure out how can we come up with our own ice
bucket challenge.
So people give a shit about Rick.
Right.
You know,
it's like when there's a hit fucking movie,
Oh my God,
it's a hit movie with vampires.
Goddammit.
Put Vampires and everything.
That's what's going to happen.
What other natural resource can we use?
Uh,
Fred,
the fresh air challenge,
the awkward for Ice Bucket Challenge.
Everybody's got to go to fucking Nantucket dump water over their head.
I Dunno.
Okay.
It's a good thing cause it's raising money,
but I gotta be honest with you.
Yeah.
You know,
there's not a lot of water left people.
If you really look at the only fresh water we got common is the polar ice caps
melting.
Do you know a lot of those blue blood counts are going around the world and
they're buying up property that sits on an aquifer because they know that water
in the future is going to be equivalent to currency.
Do you want to stand
how much little information I had before I just made that unbelievably
terrifying statement?
Do you understand that people,
why are you listening to this thing?
Um,
you know what it's going to be a rough month is the ice bucket challenge and
then also the pink month in the NFL.
All of these fucking things.
Oh man,
I really hope,
I just hope that the money actually gets to the people that need it.
Uh,
you know,
okay.
Cause that the lady,
from what I've,
I've actually read on the Internet,
so God knows if it's even remotely true.
She makes like three quarters of $1 million a year,
and I know she's raised a bunch of money and all that type of shit,
but at the end of the day,
if they weren't a bunch of women dying from breast cancer,
she wouldn't have a job.
It's just fucking weird.
I guess it's,
you can say the same thing about a doctor,
but doctors is trying to,
well,
I guess she's tried to get them better.
I Dunno.
How do you justify pulling that kind of money?
I guess just sitting there going like,
well,
I raised $100 million.
That's not even 1% I took three quarters of 1%
okay.
Then again,
three quarters,
$1 million.
You Find Ryan around a BMW,
a bet that isn't painted pinkies as it,
you know,
you want to make sure he got the resale value.
Don't yet.
What's the name of the lady that does the pink thing?
Is it Pam?
Is it Peggy?
Does her name start with p?
Uh,
all right.
Anyways,
this is the Monday morning podcast.
Every but everybody a really heavy one.
We've talked about suicide,
a ILS and uh,
breast cancer.
Hey,
how excited are you guys that the NFL football's coming back?
The NFL football whole?
Do I sign,
you know?
Okay.
Is she on that Internet?
Um,
bump,
bump bomb.
All right.
Legal zoom.com everybody.
Most Americans don't have a wealth,
but why you don't want the court dictating what happens to you or your property
or your minor children.
It didn't say you there.
You're dead.
So that doesn't make any sense.
Bill Rhea correctly.
You don't want the court dictating what happens to your property and your minor
children.
So why procrastinate?
You know what?
Most people say,
they go,
oh,
it's too expensive or it's too time consuming.
Dude.
You know what my answer is to that legal zoom.com
too expensive legal zooms prices.
They just make sense to tank consuming.
Look,
it only takes 20 minutes and legal zoom guides you from start to finish.
The service was developed by some of the best legal minds in the country and
they make it painless for you to get the legal help you.
In fact,
helping people get legally protected has been their mission and passion for over
13 years during the national make a will month.
Get special pricing on wills and living trusts by entering bur.
You are in the referral box at checkout.
Again,
that discount code is bird bu Rr.
It's national.
Make a will month,
so don't wait.
Protect your family.
Protect your future@legalzoom.com today,
legal zoom was developed by top attorneys,
top attorneys,
top attorneys to provide self health services at your specific directions,
but they are not a law firm.
Legal Zoom is hell is legal help is furnished through vetted independent
attorneys.
Legal zoom.com discount code burpee.
You are are all right then a classic here.
Dollar Shave club everybody.
Have you ever wondered why raises are so expensive?
Big Shave companies that Shadier and you for ridiculous shave technology,
you don't even need first vibrating handles that.
What's next?
A flashlight path.
Now pivot,
flex ball heads.
What's next?
MP.
Three players.
I may come up people,
enough is enough.
Joined Dollar Shave club.com for a few bucks a month.
I'll shave club delivers the world's best razors raises right to your door.
I think dollar shave club blades are better than the big companies shave the
big,
the big shape companies for a fraction of the price.
It's the same blade.
You know,
what is it made out of?
Aluminum?
The things dull in like five shaves.
It's since they give you the same blade that they charge you.
Like what?
$900 for for uh,
for,
for a fraction of the price.
I don't know what the price is here.
I'm going to get to it in the copy anyways.
It's so easy.
Go to dollar shave club.com.
Pick one of their raises.
They start at $3 a month.
Fresh blade every week.
You're out of your mind.
If you don't do this,
you don't even have to go to the damn store.
You don't need the bank.
You don't break the bank.
You know what his words,
the resort to cheap disposable to shea,
uh,
to save cash dose shape dot [inaudible] dot com is amazing.
This is a train wreck.
Read every month they ship you automatic deliveries.
You'll never forget to buy blades again.
You don't have to squeeze shaves out of a dull,
dirty old razor blade.
A you get to have you get to shave with a fresh blade every week.
This is absolutely mandatory for anyone that wants a great shave.
You deserve better than a dull blade,
don't ya?
Why don't you treat yourself no more ridiculous.
Shave technology.
Make the smarter choice like I did.
Join the dollar Shave Club revolution@dollarshaveclub.com slash bur bur.
That's dollar shave club.com/.
Bar
I'm going to get some complaints on that one.
It's not that you insulted us,
it's that you rented though bad.
No one can understand what your thang evil voice,
everybody.
If you take all your business calls yourself,
it's pretty hard to look professional to get anything done by helping you
expertly manage all of your business calls.
He voice provides you a better way to connect with your clients.
With toll free number,
professional voice greeting,
and a dial by name directory,
ie voice transforms any foam into your business phone.
When customers call,
they're automatically sent to wherever you are.
You can be at home.
The office is sitting poolside with a cold beverage.
You'll always sound like you're a fortune 500 company and you'll get all of this
for under 13 bucks a month for a limited time.
My listeners can try.
He voice for free for 60 days.
That's right,
60 days,
but this extended trial will not last forever.
You have to do it now.
Go to [inaudible] dot com and enter Promo code bill upon checkout to get your
special offer.
Make sure you hurry,
because this offer ends soon.
Go to [inaudible] Dot Com Promo Code Bill.
That's he voice.com.
Promo Code Bill,
Bravo,
India,
Lima,
Lima.
All right.
Sorry.
All right,
let's get back to the podcast here.
Um,
I skipped back to diseases and talking about dying or whatever.
um,
I'm calling 2072 for me.
I want to see the 70s again.
Uh,
that's why I'm trying to,
uh,
Amal,
that's not what I'm trying to eat.
Right.
And exercise.
I do it cause I'm vain.
You know,
I just want to look good for you people.
That's my new ending to the crying.
You like that one?
That's when I take it to another level.
That long one makes versus the fucking laugh his ass off.
Oh Jesus.
Who is this?
Oh,
it's my brother.
Hey,
I'm doing my podcast going to call you right back.
All right,
cool.
Um,
bump,
bump up.
You know what's funny is silly is that that fucking ring tone sounds like if you
gave that to anybody in Asia,
they would start with that thing and then they would have like the most amazing,
they could build that theme into the sickest fucking like opening to a,
an Olympic ceremony.
You ever,
you've ever seen you like that?
That's called positive stereotypes.
That music sounded Asian to me.
So I connected it with Asian culture with a positive result.
Is that also offensive?
You know what I mean?
If you just say stereotypical shit but as positive
do it.
Let me tell you something about those grease ball.
Italians,
they can really cook.
They're the best cooks in the world.
Like do you have some sort of weird like MCHDI lt like hot and cold.
You throw in something fucking offensive and then with a big time like positive
thing,
oh those fuckers can't drive by and they are good at math.
Okay.
We're like 50.
He needs to like half apologize and like almost get suspended.
I'm sorry.
Let's get back to the,
uh,
to the podcast.
Um,
what the hell am I?
Oh Dude.
You know what I bought?
Did I tell you guys I late night,
I'm watching TV,
right?
I had a lot of late nights this week cause I,
I had the,
uh,
it was my final week off before I was going back on the road,
the odd ball thing.
And I've,
and I've really enjoyed my time.
Um,
time off.
I haven't taken time off in,
um,
I dunno.
Fucking 10 years,
like took a significant period of time off,
uh,
just sort of been doing this shit because it's been fun.
But at some point I kind of looked up and was like,
Hey,
I need to,
I need to chill out.
So the last,
you know,
July and August,
I kind of,
you know,
rather than going out every other weekend and one or two back to back weekends,
I kind of did like w well,
I did still did two weekends in July,
but they were fun weekends and I haven't done shit in August yet.
And,
um,
it's been great.
I've been an la building up my new hour and,
uh,
I was fucking around last night down at the comedy store,
which,
uh,
you know,
is my favorite club out here.
And it was another great thing cause you,
when you go into the comedy store,
the original room,
that's where all those guys,
um,
when they came to town,
that's where they went up.
I don't even know that they had the main room initially.
Um,
they just had that,
uh,
the original room.
And that's where a Letterman,
Leno,
Robin Williams,
uh,
Sam Kinison dice,
all of those guys,
Sandra,
Sandra Bernhard,
all of them,
all of the comedy store,
Great.
Jim Carrey,
all those guys started there.
And uh,
so they have these neon signs that they made for like some of their best ones.
And it was basically it's prior,
uh,
Kinison Robin Williams.
Um,
I forget you just go around the room.
It's like,
you know,
it's like five Mount Rushmore's with the people.
So last night you went in there and they usually have them all lit up and they
only had Robin's lit up.
It was really fucking cool.
And I wanted to try out a bunch of new stuff,
so I'm like,
well shit,
there's the sign right there,
Robin Williams,
the king of fucking Improv.
So I've just been going down there and,
um,
you know,
as every hour starts out with it starts out with that idea,
that little chunk and a,
I've been fucking around with the order and I just went up there and I was did
like 15 minutes,
nothing from my special,
there was a couple of leftover ideas that didn't get developed,
um,
or didn't make this special for whatever reason.
And I'm like,
I made a choice for him not to be in the special.
They just didn't come out,
you know,
and just did my act and those jokes didn't get told.
So,
um,
just been having a great fucking time being home.
Um,
and I don't know,
now I'm getting ready to do the fucking road and I'm literally Kevin like a
panic attack.
Like,
yeah,
fuck,
I gotta get back out there again.
But I know the second I get out there,
it's going to be great.
And,
um,
I'm really looking forward to these oddballs shows because,
uh,
one I need the fucking money.
I haven't worked in two months and,
uh,
I got the downstairs hanging over my goddamn head.
Um,
you know,
what kills me is we put in this,
this,
we put in this walk in closet right downstairs,
um,
off this bathroom and you know,
it's an old house.
So it's,
it's a walk in closet,
the size of how fat people are today and how much extra shit we buy compared to
back in the day when people,
you know,
you used to take shit down to the cobbler or get the TV repair.
The TV Repairman was actually a fucking career,
you know,
he didn't just keep buying shit and then going to goodwill and throwing it at
them and then buying more shit.
So anyways,
um,
I basically,
this is how fucking hilarious women are and how much faster they're fucking
brains are in certain areas.
When we came and we looked at this house,
I was just,
I don't know what I was looking at.
I just liked it.
And when we left the house
she was just like,
what'd you think?
I was like,
I dunno.
I liked that one.
Did she kind of went like,
I liked it too.
And then we got like excited,
but she had already worked out what room was going to be hers in which closets,
when we're going to be hers.
And I have like,
I got like two half a closets,
you know back when like someone who was like for clothes for like back when
somebody was my size,
he was considered like,
I don't know what
like I would be in like the,
in the early days of the NBA at 510170170 five I don't know what you know,
on a shit franchise.
I could have actually been a power forward.
I'm just saying people were smaller back then.
If you don't realize that,
go to an old stadium,
whatever's left the Yale bowl to the rose bowl,
you the cotton bowl,
you go out to those old stadiums and what's hilarious is there a third of the
size of the new stadiums and they hold more people.
They hold like 100,000 people now.
A lot of that is because there's not luxury boxes and all that fucking space
where they have people walking around.
But when you're sitting down where they have the numbers on the aluminum
benches,
it's like they used to be back in the old Patriot's stadium.
If you stood up during the winter when everybody had that puffy coats on during
an exciting play,
if you were the last to try to sit down in your row,
you lost your seat and you had to kind of crouch down and wait for something
else.
Good to happen is people threw shit at you,
you know,
in a joking way,
going down in front knowing what the deal was.
Um,
so anyway,
so I have,
I have like these two,
like one of the closets I have is so fucking small,
like,
um,
it's basically from,
it's my shoulder with,
and it's,
it's long and it's that wide and up top it has like some,
almost like it's not baseboard,
it's sent the middle of the wall and then it has what I hang my clothes on are
you don't like nunchuck handles.
Just imagine nunchuck handles being twice the size of that.
And there's three of those.
And I,
I set them on that baseboard.
That's not a baseboard.
Halfway up the wall at a 45 degree angle,
there's three of them and then I hang clothes on them and what happens is
inevitably I reached,
when I have to grab something in the second row,
if I go to pull it off,
if I pull it off too quickly,
the whole thing falls down and takes down another row.
Um,
so anyways,
anyways,
when we,
I got to say this quietly because she said she's in the other room when we
started this fucking project.
Okay.
That walk in closet downstairs.
That was going to be mostly mine and partly hers,
but it was going to be mostly mine and I don't know what happened during the
fucking project,
but like I,
I've lost real estate down there again.
Okay.
I I,
I'm,
I swear to God and now I'm actually,
you know what I'm thinking,
I'm like,
I need to Redo the garage and I'm like,
there it is.
There it is.
I'm the stereotypical guy I have.
I am gradually being squeezed out of my house and I'm going to ice to do a bit
about that.
Then when you get married,
all your shit ends up in either the basement of the garage.
We don't have a basement,
but we have a garage.
So,
and this is the funny thing,
I'm actually looking forward to it because it's not attached to the house.
So I could,
could just kind of have that,
you know,
I can walk away from my life that has actually,
it was a fantasy of mine.
Like my dream house,
you know,
if I wasn't in this fucking business was I would live up more in the country.
Um,
not literally the country,
but I would live in a place that looked like the country but was still like a 45
minute drive to a major city.
And I always wanted,
um,
I always like old houses cause I make everything in my fucking life difficulty,
you know,
rather than just buying a new one.
I just,
I liked old shit so I would buy an old house,
fixed the whole thing up,
but it would have a garage with a room over the garage that is,
is detached from the house.
Ideally it's an old barn and down below I would have my old truck and then I
would have some selfish vehicle,
like a fucking corvette,
some two cedar.
Like,
fuck you people.
I know I'm married,
but you know,
I need some me time.
And then upstairs I'd have my drums,
guitars and all of that Shit,
you know.
And then,
you know,
of course a flat screen TV and a fuss.
Let's just go all out of fucking refrigerator,
right.
With like,
uh,
you know,
all kinds of booze in their humor,
door,
cigars,
you know,
fire,
escape up the back for horse,
whatever.
You get the idea.
Um,
so now I'm thinking,
you know,
I got this garage,
I mean,
not like I'm going to put another floor on it,
but,
uh,
eventually I'm actually at this point because of my situation in my house,
my lack of closet space and the fact that I bought this old Ludwig drum kit with
John Bonham size drums,
like a 26 inch bass drum,
it's fucking huge.
Um,
that I'm actually thinking of a,
okay.
Eventually,
I don't know,
redoing the,
I'm more excited to Redo the garage than I am the kitchen.
Put it that way because a,
that's how it works.
That's how it works.
By the way,
somebody sent me a,
um,
somebody sent me a text of,
uh,
Mel Gibson's divorce settlement.
MMM.
And you don't want,
it's funny,
the first half of it didn't even bother me.
Okay.
He was worth like 800 million.
He's been with his wife for 30 years.
She gave him seven fucking kids.
Okay.
Seven kids.
So she gets half that fortunate.
You know what?
I don't get a problem with that.
Fuck it.
Okay.
You know,
I'll take 400 million take who gives a fuck at that point you had seven kids.
God bless you.
Here you go.
I'll give you a 500 million.
I'll keep 300 million.
What fucking killed me is she gets half of all of his checks for the rest of her
life,
the rest of Mel's life.
And that's,
that's that extra shit.
Like,
it's like,
come on,
man.
He just gave you $400 million.
Okay.
You can't,
you can't
like survive on that for the rest of your life.
You got to go after that.
But I guess what it is,
is really,
it isn't even about the money.
It's more about I gave you 30 years of my fucking life.
Okay.
I absolutely blew out my fucking body for you.
And now you're going to go get with this Russian whore
and what am I to do?
Okay.
I wanted to hang with you for the rest of my life,
you know,
and enjoy our golden years.
And now I've got to go to a fucking bingo parlor to find somebody else.
Yeah,
maybe I get it.
Maybe I get it,
but I gotta be honest.
Somebody sent me that,
that,
uh,
or tweeted it to me and I read it and it actually was keeping me up at night
last night thinking about that.
Uh,
but I always end up finding the positive.
Okay.
I was just like,
you know what?
I would just completely 100% downsize my life and I would live like I'd have one
fork,
one spoon,
one knife,
one bowl.
When plate one glass,
I would just make everything super fucking simple.
MMM.
I dress like fucking Albert Einstein,
you know,
I would have the same fucking outfit every God Damn Day.
I would just make it ridiculously simple.
MMM.
Yeah.
And then I'd live in it.
I get a flat screen in a fucking pullout couch and I would just have a,
all the sports packages and a dog and that would be it.
And I would just keep it like that and I drive my old truck and that would be
it.
I would just,
that would be it.
That would be my fucking life.
I wear chuck Taylors.
I would just keep it simple.
That actually doesn't sound like a bad life,
does it?
Yeah.
I mean even that life,
that's how spoiled I am living in a first world country.
Like that's my,
you know.
Did you hear what happened to bill?
He has a place to live and can watch sports 24 hours a day and he has a dog and
he has his health,
the poor bastard.
All right.
Um,
let's get to a,
the last advertising read here.
All right,
this read,
it's prosper.
Everybody Prosper in 72 hours.
You could have $35,000 to cover your needs.
What will you do?
Pay off a high pay off a high rate credit card.
Start a business.
That home improvement project,
I can tell you right now,
even if you did that,
a lateral move where rather than all being the credit card company you owed
prosper.
If their interest is lower right there,
you just saved money and all you did was just move money from this hand or this
hand or what did I do there?
What did I do there?
Um,
what's our sponsor prosper?
It's never been easier.
Go Online,
answer a few questions and see how low fixed,
how your low fixed rate and see your low fixed rate in seconds.
Jesus,
Bill your money,
hits your account in as few as three days prospers.
The fastest growing peer to peer lender.
And they facilitated over $1 billion in loans for people like you.
They're revolutionary platform connects people looking to borrow money with
those who have money to invest.
There's no outrageous fees,
no raising interest rates,
and you'll never set foot in a bank.
Just go to prosper.com/burb B U R R to check out your rate instantly without
affecting your credit score.
That's always Nice,
Huh?
Uh,
for a limited time prosper is offering my listeners a $50 visa prepaid gift
card.
When you get alone.
Go to prosper.com/burr a up to $35 thousand dollars in just three days in a $50
gift card.
Go to prosper.com/bar.
Uh,
other restrictions apply.
See Site for details.
Gift Card is issued by Central State Bank of Florida.
Okay.
Pursuant to license from Visa USA incorporated,
all personal loans are made by Web Bank,
a Utah Charted chartered industrial bank member,
FDI.
See equal housing lender.
All right.
Um,
so that's the advertising for this week.
Let's get back to the podcast.
Um,
oh my God.
So I didn't mention I was up late night.
Okay.
And,
uh,
I was watching,
you know,
okay.
Having a couple of drinks,
this was months and months ago and it was,
it was one of those time life.
Okay.
Like music collections.
And it was this easy listening rock,
this easy listening frog music that they had and they just had like two former
stars.
So then go and who can forget this one?
You know,
the music of our childhood is so important.
Absolutely.
Randy.
And it's timeless.
What about this BG Song?
Right.
Shadow dancing or whatever the fuck they was singing.
I can't,
for some reason I'm going blank on all the fucking song.
So long story short,
I actually bought the box set and uh,
I've just been driving around.
Okay.
Listening to this fucking soft rock.
Maybe if you won't me baby if you need me.
Yeah.
That,
oh,
just all of this shit.
So they actually had a doobie brothers song Saturday in the park and I realized
that
as a comedian,
my bucket list is I want to be in the city of Boston at Karaoke.
And I want to listen to somebody sing that song just for the first line.
Okay.
You know,
da Da da Da.
But,
but it'll do,
do,
do say and the park
people in Boston don't really say,
say they say Saturday,
why don't you come over one Saturday?
Hey niggas in here,
a man selling ice cream singing it and songs.
You got to admit the
upgrade is that it's a good,
it's very positive and uplifting.
But was he really just in the park on a Saturday and just wrote a song about the
things that he was observing?
Cause it really sounds like that people dad cheering people laughing,
man shelling.
I you scream singing Chell huge songs
anyways.
And of course are you talking about your,
your box set that you got drunk at one in the morning?
Yeah.
What,
what,
what are some of the other songs that were on there?
It was like,
didn't they have like air supply on there and Linda Ron stands and Linda
Ronstadt through when the smokers so vain.
That's it.
I bet you currently that song is about you,
right?
Yeah.
All that,
all that stuff.
Just soft rock.
But you know what,
like eight cds sets.
Remember this from the,
you know.
Oh absolutely.
And I'll tell you right now,
one of my favorite things was this next guy.
What was that guy,
Rupert something or other Rupert Holmes.
Him or him at the song I never heard of in my entire life.
That was a filler song.
Then they also had all these songs from the 80s it kind of bothered me a that
they act.
I should,
they had a couple of,
uh,
but this is stuff that you would find on like a,
like an easy listening type of like old school soft rock station.
Right.
I think it's just because the little seven the way.
Exactly.
But I have like a line drawn in the sand as far as like seventies and 80s
because to me it,
why?
Because I just think as you go from decade to decade,
it's just such a jarring change because whoever's coming up,
if they're going to make it,
you know,
if you tried to do that more of the same,
you're literally going to try to float on the fumes of this other style.
It's going out.
You've got to change.
So that disco went into like new wave in the,
in the,
that metal music into grunge and then wrap took over and like,
not like rap wasn't around but like I just,
I dunno.
So for me like that seventies like how do you put in like with Saturday in the
park,
how do you put in like genesis or Mike and the mechanics in the living years?
Cause I think it's just all sort of,
I never talked to my dad,
he was a fucking Dick,
but he bought me a bicycle genre of just like soft,
not too hard.
Who'll say loan
back up.
Black singers to make me sound like I hit soul.
You burn up your friend of Michael McDonald because he is a national treasure.
I was talking about Mike and the mechanics.
What was that?
Oh No,
I've heard of him.
He was the,
he was the bearded guy who looked like the father on family ties,
but he was actually in genesis.
Oh,
okay.
I know who the father of family ties look like.
That's an awesome song.
That song,
you know some people your age 10 years younger than me.
I think that song is awesome because he was no,
because you have or have an awesome memories.
When that song came out you didn't have to pay for anything.
You know you went to school like your big thing was like,
oh my God,
I have a pimple on my face.
Like your life was easy.
Why can't I just like a song?
Because I like a song because that song sucks.
Does it really fun?
Soon as this one,
people decided that they didn't like Phil Collins cause he went into like,
no,
this is when people were loving everything that he was doing.
They forgot.
See wasn't.
One thing that people forget about Phil Collins is that guy.
He's one of the greatest drummers in the last 40 years.
He's a fucking insane drummer.
And Genesis initially was this progressive rock band,
uh,
had Peter Gabriel and it was just up monsters in this band.
And then they trim down like all of them after a while,
just like,
man,
let's just get fucking paid,
man.
Let's stop doing 20 minute jams.
Wait,
who is that band that their video is hilarious because they're on some sort of
boardwalk and they're playing like they're main playing instruments even though
they know how to do it.
That's journey.
Yeah.
Oh wait,
it's a day.
Love will fudge you break those chains that.
Yeah.
And they fucking said
no.
Sorry.
When the concepts were,
when they first started making videos are just,
you just see how they're just throwing everything against the wall and just
seeing what works.
They're like,
how about we play with no instruments,
man,
let's try to make it interesting.
Um,
it's like,
why would you,
why would you do that?
But they thought it was a really cool concept at the time,
but 80 his videos are the best.
There's so much fun.
Another ridiculous.
Another Phil Collins one.
This is Solo Phil Collins that you love.
That's on his collection,
that who can forget these songs in the,
who can forget this hit was a,
that song.
Uh,
take a look at me now.
Yeah,
that sounds awful.
Because I have a gun in my mouth
and even though I'm a rock star really,
and I can get a bunch of pussies,
I can't stop thinking about your photos.
There's really no,
there's,
there's really no need for you to take it to that dark place.
Okay.
He's got,
it is,
it is a dark place.
I went to the day of the fucking though they're the memorial for Robin Williams.
It's a sad fucking time.
And that song will make you put a fucking gun in your mouth.
I mean,
it is pretty depressing.
Thank you.
Okay.
All right.
Fair enough.
See that.
That's why you're the shit.
Why?
Cause I eventually agree with you.
No,
because if you're wrong,
you would admit it.
Yeah,
it is depressing,
but it's beautiful at the same time,
but it's very sad and it's,
it is definitely something you listened to in the dark crying and drinking
alone.
I do.
I drive down the
street like Rutan fulfill it.
Come on,
get your shit together.
You sound like you're on her front lawn.
And then she stayed with an empty space.
She's dating some bigger dude.
You will be go take care of that guy.
No,
I'll handle it.
Fill up.
You have to stop coming over the house.
I told you that moves on,
eh?
You comment back to me,
Philip?
I've called the police.
Okay.
He's,
he's got a hatchback with all his shit in the back or Phil Collins,
dumb tennis shoes that don't have fucking laces in them.
How is Phil Collins these days?
There was an article written about him.
I feel like it
rolling stone a few years ago.
Yeah.
It was really the angriest man and rock or something.
No,
no,
no.
It wasn't angry.
It was just,
he was a,
he was in a bad place.
He was going through like his third fucking divorce and physically he couldn't
play drums anymore.
But I think he's come out of that and he was also couldn't understand why he was
considered the antichrist by a lot of music fans.
Why was he can,
that's what I was wondering.
That's why I was saying earlier,
it wasn't there a period where people decided that they hated him.
Why?
Because there's this terrific seeded the,
yeah,
but this is tipping point where you become so successful and you have so much
money and when the next group of people comes up and they rebel against that
era,
like in the 80s,
disco sucked.
All right.
And to sixties with the coolest fucking thing ever.
And then the 90s came and then the 90s,
it was like the 70s were fucking cool,
boogie nights and all that shit.
And then the 80s were,
were like,
uh,
you know,
that was all cheesy horse shit and hair metal and all that fucking crap.
So he got so big,
he defined that era,
kind of like the bgs.
So I think now it's coming back around what people like him like you.
Like I'm Joe de Rosa and sensation,
the teen idol sensation from the opiate Anthony Program.
He uh,
he,
he loves Phil Collins.
Um,
oh,
he's actually going to be down the,
the goddamn comedy jam tonight.
Oh yeah.
Very good.
Is he gonna is he gonna jam man,
he's going to sing.
Oh my God,
this is incredible.
Oh,
you're excited for it.
you know how I,
you know how I love our son Joe to Rosa
as we used to call them.
We lived in New York.
He's always cause we'd agree to have him come over for dinner and villain high
kind of adopted Joe.
We all lived in New York.
Yeah,
you too guys.
The way you guys would eat like steak to the point you would eat when you get a
Ribeye,
you be eating all the gristle too.
Like I never saw that.
It was like you might have had John Candy movie where he had,
he had to eat the thing,
the fat he was eating that,
that the big steak or whatever it is.
And you have a 72 ounces.
Yeah,
no Joe and I like to get really like to get right down into it.
Joe said he would eat the bones if he could.
Okay.
I'm not going to go that far,
but yeah,
you got to get all the meat off that bone baby.
Okay.
Go grab another mic so I don't have to keep passing it over to go grab another
mic with the cord and all that.
And I'm going to read one of these questions here.
Okay.
Uh,
oh.
Hey,
this is a good thing here.
I want to thank the listeners.
Everybody went out and downloaded Nicu seps,
uh,
all things comedy member,
part of the,
part of the mob here.
Uh,
the podcast mob,
um,
who,
uh,
downloaded his,
his comedy album last last week.
Everybody was really pleased.
A lot of people hadn't heard about nick.
He's underground.
Even want to be the first person on your block to say,
Hey,
I know about this cool new comedian.
I'm seriously,
man,
this guy's the real deal in his,
uh,
his car,
his album made it to number three on iTunes.
How about that?
Hey,
uh,
the,
the microphones in the,
uh,
it's in the closet.
My half a closet that I have Nini.
Oh
God,
what do you mean?
Oh God,
can we talk about that?
Nia,
how I walked in and just loved this house.
You walked in,
love this house and also picked out all the choice spots.
It was fucking amazing how you able to do that?
How did you do that?
How can you just take all the fucking closets and leave me?
Leave me without a space in me to test this thing first for my fucking shirts
and my damn socks.
All the spots are for you.
We have er,
a closet whore.
I really don't appreciate that.
We both have the same kind of closet space and the bedroom.
Okay.
You want to trade closets?
What do you mean?
And this,
this area.
Well,
no,
I mean I have all my stuff's settled right now.
How?
How brilliant was that?
She literally gives herself time.
Do what you want to trades.
Do you want to trade closets?
What do you mean all of a sudden you don't understand English?
I understand.
Excuse me.
Don't insult me.
Don't,
don't you don't play the I'm offended card.
It has.
No,
you know exactly what's going on.
I have half a fucking closet that's hanging off this house that is not up to
code and it has a piece of fucking wood holding it up.
I told you that I would help you go to the container store and figuring out how
to organize your shit the way that I did.
That's what I did.
You saw it took me like three months to figure it all out and get it all in
there perfectly.
It told you I can help you with data and you don't have patience for that.
You don't have patients lion face.
Neil,
that slab in anything.
All right,
I told you I would help you out.
Okay,
so you don't have patience for that sort of thing and you know,
are you done with your horse shit near both of your closet?
You can walk into,
you can walk in to that one and what?
Stand sideways.
I can't really,
you know what I can do in my closets.
I know I can do that.
I can do that.
Hammertime dance in both of my closets
and you know what?
Either the back of my head on my little button nose is going
to scrape on the wall.
And I did say button nose.
I have a cute nose on my giant face.
I thought I was the one with the cute nose.
Oh,
you know something.
You took all the closet space.
Can I at least be the one with the cute nose?
Okay,
there we go.
You can have the trash for that on the podcast.
He makes cook.
Hey.
Yes.
So now we're going to don't start.
And me that downstairs closet.
That'll be done in 2016.
That is mine.
Um,
I think we're going to share it as really what we've,
I don't like the way you share.
What does that,
what are you talking about?
I'm going to have this closet up here.
I'm only putting down two closets upstairs and you can walk into and do a little
dance mega [inaudible] get down tonight cooking.
Forget this one.
Who can forget this one?
Let's get to the,
uh,
let's get to the,
the questions for the week.
Homeless with a plan.
Dear Boxcar,
Billy.
That's good.
That's actually really good.
If you found yourself homeless tomorrow,
what would you,
what would be your game plan?
Oh my God.
Where would you set up shop?
Are you and under the bridge guy?
That's the first thing I thought of.
Or a beach guy.
I'm definitely not a beach guys.
Do you sleep all day to be alert to the dangers of the night?
Oh,
is that what they do?
Yeah,
that makes complete sense.
Yeah.
The ones who can't fight,
they sleep during the day.
I think that's also just common sense though actually.
You know what they're like,
they're like rabbits.
What does that mean?
Rabbits.
So like the IRA,
but vicious.
No rabbits and just like,
uh,
they exist to keep everything else fed in nature.
That's why they fuck like rabbits.
They can have a bunch of them there.
They're like Coleslaw on the,
uh,
the meat platter.
Coleslaw.
Coleslaw really is like a filler.
It fills up the plate.
But I actually was defending Coleslaw to Paul Versey.
It's like when somebody knows how to make it,
some people don't know how to make it.
They make it all wet and fucking make yeah,
too much man is,
what about our old neighbor though?
He May.
Aha.
He made the fucking,
uh,
he made the hardy one.
Yeah.
He made it very like crisp and it's more selection.
Agree in Tangy.
Jason Law had,
makes an unbelievable fucking Coleslaw.
But Jason,
I had,
couldn't cook anything and can make a meal out of anything.
That's right.
Well,
let me,
let me finish this right here.
Okay.
Do you sleep all day to be alert to the dangers at night?
Uh,
you could beg or play drums on some pots and pans.
Thanks for the last,
uh,
listener from New Hampshire,
New Hampshire,
New Hampshire.
That's God's country up there.
That was the,
still have the,
the pollsters we ever took like a little vacation together.
Do you remember?
That was in New Hampshire in the captain's quarters.
Captain's quarters.
That's level like beach lake type business.
They've got over there.
Anyway,
I can see you.
Uh,
that was great.
That was great.
And it was low.
It was perfect white trash from me.
There's enough tatted up people with tank.
It was enough
fucking,
uh,
just sorta ate Mac and cheese is a main course meal like me with toast to like
spray that kind of like center tense SPF on you.
It was supposed to,
supposed to give you like a tan and it didn't work.
You'd like to fucking spray cans and nothing happened.
Wouldn't take just what did take like your,
your,
your skin repels color.
Like it's resistance.
Like it just won't happen for you.
It won't happen.
It just won't,
you get,
you get more freckles on my forearms and like your lower legs.
But other than that,
it's nothing.
Well,
what happens is if my suit can't take like a spray Tan essentially,
like what kind of pasty melanin deficient fucking piece of freak nature are you
that you can't even,
I'm being so mean,
right?
Not I don't give a shit.
It's true.
I will observe.
Notice I didn't interrupt you.
I will,
I will object when you say something that isn't accurate.
All right,
so obviously sleeping during the day is going to be rough for me because of the
sun.
So I either choose a beat down or I get sunburned.
So definitely gotta do you gotta do the bridge?
It's shady here for you,
but it also,
it also smells like urine.
So you know,
you gotta take the good with the bubble.
Um,
and who can forget this impactful hit?
you know,
I used to,
I used to play drums with this guy and he was into the Chili peppers and we used
to play the song that was really fun to play,
but I hated the lyrics.
Why Suck my kiss?
Oh,
okay.
I hate
fucking hated the lyrics.
Uh,
yeah,
that's a rough one.
The best thing about the red hot chili peppers way.
Yes.
Way,
right?
No,
just the whole band.
It's the whole,
the whole band is awesome.
I love Anthony Kiedis.
I liked you.
Hated his fucking,
what is Hitler mustache is Hitler mustache.
His autobiography where it was just one and then I was banging this hot chick
and I was in love and I found it.
I found inseparable.
I liked Dave.
And you know what,
when they came off to me like a bully and he was mean to fleet and I was like,
this guy's a dick and flee needs to know how to draw some fucking lines and be
like,
listen Anthony,
I'm not putting up with that shit.
He knows how to take care of himself.
Just fine.
Fleas seems scrappy and a little bit,
you know what,
he wears his heart on his sleeve.
That's what I got out of it.
Oh,
flee.
No fleas,
flea love mass and we love you would definitely,
he would be a street performer for sure.
Boxcar,
Billy.
I swear to God,
it's fantastic.
I would,
uh,
it'd be a bus.
What I did know,
I would be up during the day and I would sleep at night until I took that first
brutal ass kicking.
Like when the clockwork orange guys came around and started kicking me in the
ribs,
then I would be a broken,
ribbed,
balding Billy sleeping on the sidewalk.
Like that guy down the street.
When I walk Cleo by Clio,
always funny,
like,
you know,
she's always viewing everybody is a threat.
She actually looks down at this person with like this look of concern.
Right?
Let's see.
Okay.
Yeah.
Is this,
they can tell her and like she wants to like sniff and stuff.
[inaudible] like,
hey buddy.
Hey is everything all right?
She's curious about a lot of people.
It's interesting.
It's not necessarily in a bad way.
I don't think I see her kind of wanting to approach women a lot of time.
Well she sexist.
So yeah,
I would,
I would be a a,
I would initially be an under the bridge guy,
but I would find a bridge that nobody else was at,
um,
on.
I would also be homeless in a the nicest neighborhood I could be.
And
they'd run you out though.
You can't be a nice neighborhood with the world.
That's what I'm saying.
Like the nicest neighbor.
It could be homeless in Wa.
Cause then I could walk to a nicer neighborhood
like,
hey man,
can you help me out?
Have Arc and I would have every lie on my side,
terminal disease,
homeless,
vet,
anything I could fucking Dick.
I gotta make money,
I'd do anything.
What do you think about those people who are like,
you know,
why lie I want to get high?
Well I didn't mean it.
I am like,
I liked it when I first,
but now I think it's hacky.
Okay.
You need to get a new,
you need to get a blue a slogan.
They're clever.
Homeless people.
Absolutely.
Alright,
fiancee.
And we got to get moving here because we've got to get the dog on the uh,
uh,
we're already an hour and fiance getting crazy fit.
Hey Billy biceps.
Uh,
today at least say that.
Yeah.
Oh,
why you didn't like it?
Cause it was sort of complimentary.
Now come on.
How good a shape.
My end right now.
You look amazing.
Thank you.
Uh,
today I have an odd problem than I am hoping you can lend me some advice.
it should have said and I'm hoping that,
I'm hoping that,
I'm hoping.
I have always been on an on and off gym rat.
My fiance is amazing looking and worked as a Disney world dancer,
which kept her in fantastic shape recently.
She took a new job and sits behind a desk all day.
Looking for a new way to stay fit.
She started heading to the gym with me,
always great for a while to recently she found a new workout program.
Now she's addicted to lifting and with the advice of a personal trainer is
looking to become a bikini competitor.
Sounds great.
Right?
Not so much.
First off,
most bikini competitions are crazy ripped manly,
ripped a,
if I was into that I would,
I change teams.
Uh,
next issue,
not me.
I'm going to keep going.
Would you want your man to look like a woman?
Uh,
next issue is that she doesn't want it.
All right.
Talking to talk about my ignorance at the end of this,
I realize 40% of why that was a ignorant comment.
Next issue is that she doesn't want to have fun anymore.
We are in the mid twenties no kids and live alone.
We normally do a little partying,
which has gotten cut out to save all calories.
And last off is that she really is a 10 now her swinging dick in the weight room
throws lines.
No,
no,
no.
Now every swinging dick in the weight room throws lines that are every day.
I trust her and have no worries,
but it gets under your skin for these selfish reasons.
I could use some advice.
I support her no matter what,
but still want her to have fun and have no interest in dating a man.
But I have no interest in dating man.
Any good idea?
Maybe the lovely Nia could yell at me and set me straight.
You really?
Yeah,
totally.
I'd have a reputation here.
You're going to,
you're going to fucking get it.
You're hey.
Oh.
Aren't you the fucking authority on everything?
Get off you.
Oh,
you're going to get it.
Shut up,
Nia.
No,
I will not set up.
This guy needs to shut up because,
oh,
you feel on a certain kind of way because your girlfriend is,
you know,
growing without you and you still want to lie around and be a tub of shit.
No,
I'm just kidding.
Yeah,
that's completely inaccurate.
Uh,
I know,
uh,
we know somebody that has done bikini fitness,
a female,
and she doesn't look like a dude at all.
There are the girls that are due really the steroids shit,
which is,
yeah,
that's,
that's not a good luck.
Um,
and then there the girls who are do the natural,
uh,
thing,
there's different like categories of it,
but they're like the natural girls and then they're the ones that look like
Arnold Schwarzenegger.
Like circa 1983 is the,
that obviously you don't want that.
I totally get that.
I wouldn't,
you know,
if a girlfriend was going in that direction,
that'd be like,
ah,
no.
So of course,
but yeah,
she's getting in shape and she really loves it now.
She's not going to want to go out drinking.
She's not going to want to go out.
Like that's kind of just part of it.
Then they don't drink water,
so it sucks everything up right before the,
the thing.
And then they go out and they paint themselves brown and then they go out there
and they got literally the show shredded.
They had like veins coming out of where their Bush should be.
Mckeany she's not going to end up looking like a dude.
I really don't think that that's a real fear that you have.
So you really need to stop it with that like a fucking break.
Like just know that when you're lifting weights all of a sudden she's going to
be low.
Who saw up like she has to keep the long hair though.
She has to keep the long hair because eventually if she competition.
Okay.
Alright.
Cause all I'm saying is eventually if she keeps working out,
her ass is going to feel like an elbow and if she has the short hair,
you could really feel like wink,
I'll back off.
Well that's the last thing.
She's not going to end up looking like a dude.
You're just getting insecure because like you said,
the dude's
in the weight room.
We're starting to talk to her and so when you're trying to deal with that by
being like I don't want to Vulcan data man.
Okay,
calm down sweetie.
Yeah,
but you know something on the other side though herself,
he cares about her.
He was worried he's going to lose her.
You've been a dose storm,
right?
No.
He's being a Douche by being like,
I don't want to date a guy if I wanted that.
I switched teams like throwing that ridiculous shit in there.
I just come out with it.
Just say you're feeling insecure because she's looking better than ever and
these meathead dudes I could probably rescue you are now talking to me and I pay
on a certain kind of way.
That's exactly what's going on.
You don't need it.
If you want people to hear your point,
you can't shit on him like that.
I'm sorry,
did you just tell me that?
Yeah.
Cause that's what you do.
But no,
no,
the shits on everybody,
Bro.
What?
I want somebody here my point.
Okay,
well maybe I do.
Oh,
I'm just saying,
well maybe I can fucking hear it from you,
but I can tell you this and yet there is a certain point we're woman gets in
such ridiculous shape.
You,
you lose a lot of the femininity.
How would have you say that fucking word.
Okay.
Yeah.
You want to take a little softening.
I understand something a whole lot too.
Yeah.
And I know you don't want to feel like you're cradling your buddy in a foxhole
trying to fucking hold your breath during the mustard gas.
That kind of makes all willy take a fucking vacation.
Well,
it has.
I mean that's the thing though.
It has she even gotten to that point or is he just like freaking out?
She's going to do the competitions.
Yeah,
but as,
as I said in the beginning,
there are competitions where you got more of a natural ally of his feelings.
I validate his feelings if he just be honest with his feelings and stop the
official reasons.
Okay.
I could use some advice.
He had a sense of humor maybe can yell at,
yeah,
he's being funny.
Okay.
Well I'm,
I'm a little playfulness there.
Okay.
All right.
Geez.
Slowly getting all upset about it.
Why are you getting all,
cause I want some closet space to
this part of the team is all about men feeling emasculated and how you need to
get the fuck over it.
Yeah.
Look at that.
See that what it was,
what I've always said about women point at me,
I'm pointing right at you.
Everything that you guys don't want us to do to you.
You guys do to us in a fucking heartbeat and you don't even see it because we
can beat the shit out of you so you don't fucking see.
You don't see the uh,
the humanity in us.
Why don't you cute you doing that,
right?
Woo Hoo,
hoo.
Hook.
Can you add,
can we make that some sort of sound effect that I can hit every time you're
like,
we've guys do what?
You guys are like this,
but what do you do it?
It's point.
I'm going to hit a button.
Have you go,
Ooh,
cause that's exactly what you are good.
And how can I do that?
Back to,
you know,
you see again,
you're always like,
yeah,
see cause this and this.
It's like I have never seen who I feel like I don't want to go stick your face.
I don't want to,
I don't want to give ratio but do it.
I swear to God,
fucking straight white men love trying to keep score about shit.
It's like say,
well you guys do this,
we can't do this.
But then that and that,
it's like you guys are as fighting so hard to maintain the status quo.
It's actually laughable.
The kind of ridiculous things that'll come out of your mouth in order to like
keep things the way they used to pay back when this goddamn country meant
something and stood some fun for something.
I'm literally talking about closet space and you turn me into some guy in
Mississippi burning,
you know something.
What you just fucking did that whole ridiculous thing at this status quo.
What am I an 80 year old Republican,
do you think?
I honestly have meetings with my other white male straight friends.
Wait a talk about the status quo and how to maintain,
how to maintain it.
This country is getting over run with the ones,
the Fab it is that,
you know what it is?
The women who liked to lift weights and they're not,
they're not a woman anymore.
God dammit.
Put a skirt on and get back in the kitchen.
Yeah.
And you know what's funny is you can fucking sit there and go off on all these
man boys with their fucking hoodies who are in their thirties and talk all
awkward in that Shit.
How you're fucking over there.
Come on.
You.
You know what it is the,
yeah.
You don't,
you,
you don't have a,
you don't have an ability to step outside yourself and just see how ridiculous
and dumb you really are.
Is that what,
you're not a smart person and nobody likes you.
All right,
let's move to the next one as though things like category fish tanks.
Did we even answer this thing?
Uh,
well,
why don't you answer?
I would answer it this way.
All right.
You got it.
She's going to be in great shape,
which is a good thing.
It's better than Dayton of fatty.
Uh,
sorry.
Um,
okay.
This is the deal.
I shouldn't have said that.
That was extra mean.
I didn't mean that,
but uh,
she's only going to be in that gross shape the few days before the competition
was,
she's completely fucking emaciated and actually doing damage,
more damage than good to her body,
depriving her vitals of water.
Um,
and that awful fucking 10 and no,
it's gross.
If you seen him go out there,
they look fucking the reason.
First of all,
they look,
you know what they look,
I talked about they look several raceless.
You want to play the race card?
They look raceless like I'll look that terrible shade of Brown.
No,
they,
they look like a,
what's that fucking dead meat that you eat?
You go and you buy a big stick of it.
It's not even Brown.
It's Orange at seven 11.
Beef Jerky,
Slim Jim beef jerky was a race.
That's what they look like.
Slim Jim.
Yeah.
Stammer do are slim Jim.
But like I said,
there's Def,
there's several different kinds of categories of those fitness competitions for
women.
It's not all like Schwarzenegger style,
so it's just,
yeah,
I dunno.
Sorry,
I gave him my opinion already.
Yes.
Guys don't know I'm a normal
guy.
Was your senator.
No guy ever goes a god.
Geez.
You see the biceps on that chick is like that though.
They liked that.
Really like worked out ABS popping.
Listen,
guns blazing.
Can I tell you something?
This somebody out there fucking a rug.
Okay.
You can pick up anything in the fucking world is something that's,
look at the fan over there.
There's probably some guy that likes to jerk off in front of it and feel the
wind oscillating.
Yeah.
There's somebody into everything that,
I'm just trying to be the white guy.
He just painted me to be all right.
Fish tanks.
Dear Barnacle Billy.
My very clever with the CRM.
I have my,
this is smart.
My friend just spent 1000 bucks on this crazy fish tank and exotic fish to go
with it.
Yeah.
Yeah,
to each his own,
but what's the call here?
That's an absolute waste of money.
It's not like he's,
he has an awesome apartment that it fits in with the decor.
On the other hand,
that goes to prove he might have an honest passion for fish tanks.
I don't know how to now.
I don't know how to feel.
Please give me your thoughts.
Come back to Seattle.
So yeah,
he sounds like a pothead.
I like how this is as bothering him enough that he's got to write you about it.
I'm like,
what the fuck?
It doesn't die.
You're living in this shit hole.
You got this thousand.
Yeah.
So there's that was going to say,
it's not like it was an awesome apartment that fits in with the decor,
eh.
You know,
on the other hand goes to vice,
he might have been on his passion for fish tanks.
I think he covered the topic.
Yeah,
he just likes me.
You know what?
Fish in the like,
aquariums are very like calming to some people.
So it might be like,
oh,
why are you making,
why are you making that noise?
Because that's that fucking like somebody said that,
and I've never heard a doctor say that.
I've heard that repeated.
Yeah.
Someone who left the doctor to say what soothes do you are not in order to make
it legitimate,
they're the ones that know how to take your blood pressure.
You're right,
so they would actually know.
Okay.
How do you know that that didn't come from the aquarium industry and when fish
fell out of favor around 72 73 fill out of faith and people stop getting
aquariums.
Did you ever hear that?
That rumor that JC Morgan had like an octopus or something like that or if what?
I've seen a,
I've seen video of it.
No,
he has like sharks and shit.
That's kind of cool.
No,
he doesn't.
He doesn't have to take the little fishies.
He doesn't have to take his kids to the aquarium.
He just takes them to the living room.
Right.
There's no charge style or nothing like he could charge money for his aquarium.
I think I heard somebody was saying that maybe he was going to get a uh,
an octopus.
I have no idea.
I'm just happy that he's still around and can make that decision to be honest.
You,
I'm looking forward
to when he gets back to the clubs,
it seems like buying fish is a pretty harmless a habit.
It can be a little like what the fuck now if you've got someone living in this
shithole apartment and the spinning out some dollars off fit,
that's fucking ridiculous.
You know when I was a kid my dad could be worst thing my dad used to,
we used to,
we used to have Puranas.
Oh you did?
Yeah,
we used to call him and it was always the same name Charlie.
We had the Borana Charlie and you'd throw the goldfish in and he would just
destroy them.
Oh my God.
So much stuff is doing it make sense and that he would eat like you'd put in
like I remember one time we put like the whole bagging.
You've never told me that you own Paranas and that you five photos with like we
had a Purana that my dad had another thing,
another tank,
it was called an Air Awana.
I swear to God.
And it was this eel looking like fish and that thing used to also eat fish and
it would just call it like just fucking like lash out or grab him.
And one time the fish was too big and it kept hitting it and hitting it and
hitting it and we were all sitting there laughing cause we thought it was funny.
Then afterwards we started feeling bad for the fish so my dad reached in,
took it out and brought over to the counter and took a knife and cut its head
off and then throw it back in a tank.
And that's my childhood.
Once again,
so many things is becoming,
oh stop it.
And someday when the shit hits the fan and the food supply ads and you can't cut
the fish off dead head cut the fish off.
They kept the head.
I think I have dyslexia.
Do I?
I mean I can't read,
I can't even speak.
No it's not that.
You know what it is?
Cut the fish off the head.
It's your add.
Your brain moves faster than your mouth and like I know somewhere in there is an
insult.
You,
you kind of skimming things it because you're already,
you want to be like down here or when you're up here.
Is there a lady I told you.
Okay.
Get it under control.
How can you just fuck and diagnosed me?
I'm right though.
Remember when,
remember when Y'all done adult ADHD quiz?
I made you take that quiz.
I crushed that quiz.
I got every answer right.
Crushed it by being like,
yes,
you have 80 hates Dave.
We recommend you to like see somebody click on this link and Adam and Adam and
Adam Levine is sitting there like,
Hey,
I also have ADHD,
but that didn't prevent me from being a huge asshole rockstar.
Why don't you like him?
I like him and turned on that guy.
You loved him when he first came out.
I liked him,
Huh?
Yeah.
I told like Maroon five.
I did like it,
but at the more he started talking,
the more,
the less I liked him,
but I do like,
well maybe if he didn't steal his fucking music,
he could just be out in the road doing that instead of spinning around in a lazy
boy going,
I want to put you on my team to sing row,
row,
row your boat.
All right.
Hot Dogs.
Everybody 20 of money in [inaudible] five,
and he wants to be a bigger star.
That's why he's on the voice.
That's why he's shilling ADHD medication.
You don't know.
You're right.
I don't know.
Hot Dogs.
Bill,
my girlfriend,
uh,
it's grossed out by hat.
I was wondering why he didn't go Billy Frankfurt to uh,
my girlfriend has grossed out by hot dog.
She says they're made of gross parts of many animals.
She's right.
I told her I would get it.
You agree with the women on this?
I told her I'm aware which is,
which is why I only eat like 12 a year.
Hey,
if you did coke once a month,
you wouldn't have a problem.
That's true.
See,
we're not encouraging people to do,
but if you are just do it once a month,
once a month,
which isn't that much,
uh,
a coop at a time,
that ball and he's supposedly a couple at a time and only at BBQs BBQs and my
crazy that I think this guy might be black.
Why Barbecue?
You put coop,
you know,
like Coupe Deville basically.
Now you're saying that because this is a Cadillac driving hot dog eating
barbecue,
eating black guy.
That's what I'm guessing.
So she says she won't kiss me for hours after eating one.
So I told her I won't kiss her for hours after drinking coffee.
And let me tell you bill,
she drinks a good amount of coffee side I do here.
Um,
awful.
You turned into the unaccepted skid not,
you didn't turn into it.
You made it worse.
You'd be like,
Oh,
you're going to be a Douche.
I'll be even a bigger Dushan now you guys aren't going to be kissing
you guys to fight about.
Yeah,
she's going to bang the guy at the coffee truck and a,
you're gonna fuck a girl in the bleachers.
I really love how he eats hot dog so much that his girlfriend is like,
I will refuse to kiss you because he eats that many fucking hot dogs that it's
an actual issue.
Listen,
I understand why you eat them.
And I also understand that she doesn't want to kiss the after breath of a pig's
ass hole.
Yeah,
that's a good point.
I mean,
I would never not kiss you because you're in a hot dog.
That's a little extreme for sure.
Oh,
and by the way,
coffee,
breath,
coffee.
Fucking discuss the worst than hot dog breath.
It is Ryan.
I think they should put coffee in the water that they have.
Hotdogs in.
Coffee,
dogs,
coffee,
Doug's dark coffee.
Uh,
coffee.
Either way.
It's dumb of you guys to be writing about this.
So yeah,
as you guys should be a more mature couple of like myself and leave.
All Right,
book suggestion.
Billy Shakespeare.
Eh,
that's good.
That's another good one.
I'm catching up on old podcast and heard you talk about World War II books.
There was,
that was a year ago.
Read anything good lately.
Also.
What magazine,
What magazine Pique your interest piqued your interest.
Um,
he wrote peak.
Was he asking about dirty magazines there?
Um,
yeah,
I was in a world war two books.
I was a year ago and I was into that for like a month and then La and my brain
goes over here.
So recently,
what did I do?
I don't know what I've been reading about.
And,
uh,
I don't fucking know.
I,
I go through periods of reading and not reading it right now.
I haven't been reading you read drum magazines though.
Those are the magazines and uh,
that you read a lot and rolling stone.
I read rolling stone.
Yes I do.
Even though you fucking shit on that magazine.
I just,
I believe you said it was wack.
I said that awhile ago.
I actually,
I I like reading rolling stone.
I rather read about the real life stuff than the celebrity interviews.
I just feel like the celebrity interviews of like not as,
not as great as they used to be,
but I love reading about,
I mean very real stuff,
but they're in the music soldiers with like PTSD and like any kind of like
Internet business thing.
There was an article about these two people that met on vine and started like
courting each other on vine.
They met in real life and of course it didn't really work because you,
you're in a relationship with somebody online,
you don't really know them.
And things went south and she accused him of rape and it was just this whole
fucking terrible situation.
Blame that on vine.
I was showing me showing a bar back in the day where you don't really know that
either.
I know,
but you at least met them in real life.
I blame people who have relationships with people online for six months that
they've never met in real life.
That's a very different situation than being in the same way.
10 years.
You have.
You haven't.
You haven't met the real me yet,
man.
Alright,
dilemma.
Bill,
Bill and Nia,
if she's around.
Oh she is definitely around this time around.
Imagine you're in a perfect relationship.
I don't have to imagine it.
I'm living it.
Jesus.
Nobody believes that one of your sheets,
one of you cheats and it's over.
Would you rather be the one who cheated so you,
so your image of the other is always perfect or be the one who got cheated on so
you can have pride in the fact that you are a good person.
Rough question.
If you immerse yourself in the ideas of both for your own fucking amusement.
Terrible question.
I'm not now I'm not answering that.
That's stupid.
All right,
well let's just,
we got to do a dilemma.
All right.
If,
um,
we were in a plane crash
and we're in snowy mountains.
I know you don't like the cold.
No.
Would you read that?
Rather would you rather that I lived and I AAU
or you lived and you ate me?
Now we're the only ones on this brain that it's come to that.
So here we go.
We can't eat the pilot and the stewardess,
the as and the other paths.
We were in a very small plane.
Oh,
I see.
Um,
white meats better for you than dark meat.
Excuse me.
Dark meat tastes better.
Um,
I could not eating you.
I want to do that.
What?
I'm going to tell you this right now.
Well,
the way you've handled closets in here,
that's not even a life and death fucking situation.
He would totally be like,
by BB,
you know what you do?
I'd be sitting there like still kind of conscious and you do what Tony Soprano
did.
The Christopher,
you just reach over and pinch my nose.
Broke my heart when I saw that scene.
Oh my God.
Oh,
that was horrifying.
I,
oh,
that was terrible.
That and Adriana hurt me the worst on that shelf.
God,
I fucking love that show so much.
Remember there was a time where I was watching like every episode on demand,
like every day,
cause I had just went back.
I was obsessed with my sopranos.
I just love the fun.
I loved that period of time.
Yeah,
that was a great period in your TV watching you kind of gone down hill.
Yeah.
You have peaks and valleys and right now you are,
you're a,
I'm watching a good TV on Netflix and I'm watching the bad TV on actual tea.
Yeah.
Well that's going to stop when football season starts.
By the way,
that's less than a couple of weeks of college football.
Pro Football.
Oh boy.
Hey fern,
lung Quist,
SCC football.
I don't know what any of those words mean.
All right.
Well,
it's,
it means a lot to me.
It's exciting.
All right,
everybody,
that's the podcast for this week.
Um,
I got an,
I thought I had odd ball dates this week,
but I'm,
I'm definitely doing the Jones beach one,
but I don't know what's going on with Virginia ticket sales are run not where
they need to be.
This is not my call.
So we'd either might happen or it might not happen.
I don't know what's going on with Virginia.
We thought that you guys liked comedy will thanks a lot everybody.
Virginia is for lovers.
It's not for comedians.
That's right now for psycho comics.
Um,
all right.
That's it.
Yay.
Um,
that's a podcast.
Everybody go fuck yourselves.
I'll talk to you next week.
Thank you for listening.
Bye.